I think I'm at the point where I just
want to go in and get it over with you
know what I mean because it's just been
a long time
Joe Giudices prison sentence is
officially over with but he's not
exactly a free man after a 41-month
sentence in federal prison Joe an
Italian citizen is now in the custody of
ice the Immigration and Customs
Enforcement Wing of the Department of
Homeland Security this news comes after
rapper 21 Savage was also detained by
ice which alleged the british-born
rapper has been in the US illegally for
more than a decade and I spokesperson
tells et that Joe will remain in their
custody until he is given a court date
for his previously filed appeal to his
deportation Joe's family attorney shared
in a statement to ET quote his lawyers
and his family are hopeful that justice
will prevail and mr. Giudice will return
home to his wife and four daughters who
love him and miss him
my daughter's adore him he's their life
like literally I I'm their mom I've been
doing everything for them but all they
care about is their father in 2014
Teresa and Joe pled guilty to multiple
charges of fraud and were given
consecutive sentences the Real
Housewives of New Jersey Starr served
her time first starting in January 2015
she was released that December then Joe
started his sentence in March 2016 and
in October 2018
Teresa opened up to et about her
husband's possible deportation music I
just got out and he said he said they
want to deport me he's got to come home
you know we have four daughters
how was he was he scared no he never
shows me that he's scared
you know I don't he's not like that you
know with me did he cry no no Joe kept a
pretty tough demeanor ahead of his
prison sentence when et spoke to the
couple until the father of four
reflected on missing time with his kids
that's I think the hardest part of
everything you know I think going to
jail is easy part I'm sure not an easy
part of understand yourselves at home -
oh yes
to be hard if I didn't have a family
kids I wouldn't even care at all but I
mean yes I mean I mean I for sure I'm
gonna definitely miss my kids in there
and miss my wife and family I mean that
for sure
et confirmed the 46 year old had been
ordered to be deported at the end of his
sentence
last November Joe filed a last-minute
appeal to dispute his order and while
Teresa had previously been adamant that
she and Joe would never divorce now I
mean right no we're gonna be a family
and and we're gonna fight this and get
through this she's had a change of heart
here's what she said at the Real
Housewives of New Jersey season nine
reunion just weeks ago what you're
saying is that you would split us that's
what you're saying I mean I'm not doing
a long-distance relationship I
understand I totally understand you know
I want somebody with me everyday Joe's
lawyer James letter tells us the family
remains quote optimistic that once his
appeal is heard he will receive relief
and return home to his family of course
we will keep you updated with all the
latest so be sure to subscribe to ET
until next time I'm Courtney teza know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]